il est exactement 9h20 du matin est tel
que promis le train arrive en gare à
iaroslav avec une précision militaire
mes enfants sont au rendez-vous en rang
d'oignon est impatient plusieurs sont
des cadets il concède ne pas trop savoir
à quoi s'attendre
je sais que la russie aide la syrie et
lui fournit des armes dit david
mais samedi rien de plus beau gosse moi
au contraire ça me donne envie de servir
mon pays explique pavel qui est déjà
membre de l'armée des jeunes mise sur
pied par vladimir poutine
ça fait des mois qu'on leur parle de ce
fameux convoi qui parcourt l'a réussi
gracieuseté du président cette
exposition a été organisée à la demande
du président vladimir poutine
les objets que vous y verrez sont des
échantillons de ce que nous avons saisi
aux terroristes de l'équipement
militaire qui démontre le niveau des
aides internationales fournit aux
terroristes dit que les portes s'ouvrent
les invités se bousculent pour entrer
dans ce musée ambulant où sont exposés
l'artillerie les armes toutes sortes de
reliques que l'armée russe prétend avoir
saisi adech en syrie depuis 2004 comme
ce drone qui peut transporter des
petites bombes artisanales
ce sont les terroristes qu'ils ont
concocté avec du bois et du plastique
explique un soldat mais qu'il soit
impossible de le prouver
ici la notion d'effet secondaire
si l'image et le message qui conte
comment se nomme mois
blindés américains a voyagé de l'irak en
syrie et a été convertie par les
terroristes pour mener des attentats
suicide explique cet autre soldat qui ne
fait aucune distinction entre des ch et
les rebelles syriens qui se bat contre
le régime de bachar al assad
ce qui est bien c'est que la guerre tour
à sa fin les terroristes ont cédé leur
position ça ne peut que nous rendre
fiers ce père de famille alors que les
enfants peut se régale de voir grandeur
nature cette machine vie qu'ils ne
connaissent que sous forme de jouets 8
james à deux ou trois ans cette
exposition est destinée à l'éducation
patriotique des enfants il faut leur
apprendre dès l'enfance que notre pays
est fort pour qu'il grandisse tels que
nous sommes prêtes à aider
mais cette enseignante d'origine
syrienne n'est pas convaincue du mérite
d'un tel spectacle
l'isis propagateur au programme
si tu as this exhibition mais dit
aborder
pour elle c'est surtout une façon de
convaincre l'opinion publique d'adhérer
à l'intervention à série pour soutenir
le régime série
[Musique]
ce train des trophées comme on l'appelle
a déjà attiré plus d'un million de
spectateurs traversée 62 villes et
villages du nord au sud et d'est en
ouest y compris en crimée l'équivalent
de 25 mille kilos mais pour moi c'est de
la propagande et ça ne rime à rien ce
jeune qui nous a demandé de cacher son
visage car critiqué l'armée
à quelques pas des troubles le rendre
heureux dit il en parlant de ce wagon
qui exhibe un mini laboratoire avec
lequel les terroristes auraient fabriqué
des bombes de chlore selon les
explications données aux visiteurs mais
pas un mot sur les attaques au gaz que
le régime syrien aurait mené sur des
civils avec la complicité de la russie
assad et son armée ne veulent que
libérer leur territoire pourquoi
aurait-il besoin de tuer des civils cet
homme qui est venu sensibiliser son fils
de 4 ans aux dangers de la guerre
quelques mètres des tentes ont été
érigées pour le recrutement de rares
tête à tête avec des généraux qui
répondent aux questions des curieux
je leur ai demandé où ge pourrait être
déployée et quel est le salaire dit
vitali 18 ans pour qui s'enroulent les
n'a rien à voir avec le patriotisme
surtout très difficile de nos jours de
trouver un bon emploi
l'armée peut être une option alléchante
explique dimitri en plus les soldats
nous racontent leurs exploits de quart
d'heure
c'est très motivant
[Musique]
ne serait ce que pour ça malgré toutes
les critiques
le train des trophées le train de la
propagande aura peut-être accompli sa
mission
[Musique]